I haven't had time to look at the
entirety of this decision but I am being
told by a producer here that Aereo it
has been found by the Supreme Court did
violate broadcasters copyrights so a
huge win for broadcasters here it was a
6-3 decision that broadcasters copyright
laws were violated so again big win for
broadcasters big loss for Aereo and some
would argue a big loss for cloud
computing what does this mean for the
future of the cloud so that was some of
the big back and forth and again to back
this up a little bit the aerial business
model they argued was perfectly legal
because it was it's based on tiny
antennas dime sized antennas they're
charging in about a dozen different
markets people about eight bucks a month
to retransmit broadcast programming
broadcasters of course make billions of
dollars 3.3 billion dollars last year in
those retransmission fees this would
have called that into question now it
looks like that structures Megan Megan
one one thing to point out we're going
to have to obviously read through the
details that read through the ruling and
find out what kind of an impact it does
have on or collateral impact it might
have on cloud computing I suspect that
we never know sometimes the justices
thread the needle fairly carefully but
63 is important isn't it because this
was not a 5-4 decision Justice Samuel
Alito initially recused his himself and
was back in the case and now we have a
fairly decisive ruling from the Supreme
Court you know and it's interesting I
again haven't been able to see the
breakdown yet but Chief Justice Roberts
during the arguments made the case that
that area or seem to indicate that he
felt that area was really trying to use
a loophole here to get around copyright
law so I have to wonder if that's if
that got some of the other justices on
board with that line of thinking that
this was area was trying to use sort of
a sneaky way to skirt broad dude but
copyright law and and circumvent the
broadcaster's right